welcome to the special report homepage  I'm Bret Baier we had a good discussion  on the panel tonight about President  Trump's plan to reduce prescription drug  prices and the latest on the Russia  probe and all of those payments to  Michael Cohen you can see the segment  right here on the website along with a  report by John Roberts also in the home  page rich Edson with Secretary of State  Mike Pompeo as comments about his trip  to North Korea and the upcoming summit  between President Trump and Kim Jong on  Monday the u.s. opens its new Israeli  embassy in Jerusalem Palestinians plan  to protest there will be there will see  at 6 p.m. Eastern on Fox News Channel  four special report